our first date we breathed each other
that was all we did
and then our second day
just when you thought nothing was
certain anymore enter megan fox and
machine gun kelly and their year of
unwavering romance
[Music]
i knew right away that he was what i
call a twin flame ever since cementing
their relationship the couple's flame
has only burned hotter let's take a look
back to where it all began so we're
actually two halves of the same soul i
think wow and i said that to him almost
immediately what because i i felt it
right away that was megan talking about
their instant connection on the set of
midnight and the switchgrass during the
lovebirds first joint press appearance
in july of 2020. our trailers were next
to each other so i just waited outside
on my trailer steps
every day i worked just i had no idea
glimpse of eye contact and i would just
sit there and like hope well machine gun
whose real name is colson baker aka
buddha
lambie you haven't gotten that one in a
long while but you gotta earn that one
back cookie
blonde angel baby
am i missing any yeah so back to what we
were saying mgk didn't have to hold out
hope for too long due to covet
production on the film was halted in
march 2020 after one week you belong to
me you understand what i'm saying
now lift up that skirt no the cast and
crew were flown back from puerto rico he
shot only for two days
and that's how i met him
and then all the rest of that developed
afterwards two months later megan and
coulson sparked relationship rumors
after grabbing takeout in calabasas
california it's something the actress's
ex-husband brian austin green addressed
on his podcast at the time megan and i
have talked about him and and they're
they're friends at this point and
from what she's
expressed he's a really
just nice genuine guy
and uh and i trust her judgment she's
always had really good judgment now
about a year and a half later a source
tells et that mgk is ready to propose
quote they're very in love and beyond
obsessed with each other they're ready
to take this next step in their
relationship
let's break down what we've learned
about this passionate couple through
he's
2021
charismatic he's so naturally gifted
and he's so intense in february colson
revealed on the gram that megan was
literally his bloody valentine
look closely at this pic and you can see
the drop of blood he wears around his
neck of course the dirt actor's post
stirred up some controversy but here's
how he explained the jewelry to ellen in
may she was actually going out of town
to film a movie and um this was really
new in our relationship i was
you know like
i didn't have a passport either so she
was going out uh to bulgaria
and so i was kind of freaking out like
oh you're gonna leave and i can't even
come see you or whatever and
yeah i mean some people give like a
handkerchief to their partner or
whatever she gave me her dna
things are definitely going strong now
but in july megan told who what where
that she had some reservations before
jumping into the whirlwind romance she
even made a list of pros and cons quote
when i met him i knew instantly that
this is a soul i've traveled with before
that this was a soul mate connection and
that there was a purpose here there was
my logical brain chiming and being like
this will never work for 101 reasons we
also learned that megan lets coulson
take the lead when it comes to style
usually i build my outfit around
whatever he's choosing because he's way
more into fashion than i am and
his closet is wild case in point the
couple's look at the 2021 mtv vma's
y'all always dress the part how did you
coordinate these outfits this evening
yeah did machine gun take the lead and
then meg and you were like oh
he was like you're gonna be naked
tonight and i was like whatever you say
daddy whatever daddy says oh
i don't know if this is family friendly
y'all neither was the implied message in
these september selfies from megan he's
the most talented boy in the world some
other things we learned in 2021 megan
and coulson actually met for the first
time years ago i'll tell you where we
first met where did we first meet at a
gq party fox i'll actually tell that
story right you said to me you smell
like weed and i said
i am weed and then
you vanished and we learned it didn't
take them long to start using the l word
mgk sharing this tweet celebrating their
one year anniversary of that exchange in
may as for another thing the couple
seems to love well you see the celebs
are out tonight megan fox and machine
gun kelly
getting the vip treatment here at the
ufc attending sporting events with some
of their famous friends also in the
building travis barker and courtney
kardashian enjoying
the festivities here at ufc travis and
courtney got engaged in october so could
mgk and megan be next it's hard to top
that one man only time will tell
i mean he's not allowed to have other
hoes in his music video
it's the queen or no one
[Music]
you